[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIHAI IONESCU: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to another session of
"Developers Live." We're going
to talk about payments,
Wallet APIs, very
exciting session today.
We're going to start with
some announcements.
There have been quite a
few things happening
since we last talked.
Then we have a demo.
My colleague here, Peng,
will demo some of the
latest APIs in action.
And, of course, we're going to
end with a Q&A session and
answer your topics
raised on the
forums and on the Moderator.
So let's start with some
announcements.
A very exciting week, so what
happened this week?
PENG YING: Yeah, so I can
finally talk about one of the
products I've been working
on for quite a bit.
Well, I mean, this is
like the second
iteration of the product.
But it's something that I think
is really useful to
developers and merchants.
So the product itself is called
Google Wallet for
online commerce.
And the idea is that, right now,
purchasing on the mobile
web is something that's very
time-consuming and difficult.
I've seen statistics that state
something like 97% of
all mobile web purchases
are canceled.
What we set out to do is we set
out to make this process
more frictionless.
And in order to do so, what
we're doing is we're
leveraging the power of Google
Wallet to enable these
transactions.
And what I mean by that is
anybody who has made a
purchase on Google Play, who has
made a purchase on Chrome
Web Store, or bought something
with Google Wallet has their
credentials stored
within the cloud.
And what Google Wallet for
online commerce does is it
allows merchants to leverage
these credentials.
So when you allow a customer
to purchase Google Wallet,
what happens is we pass
over a one-time use
card to your servers.
And you can process the
transactions with your typical
transaction rails.
And then I'll be showing a demo
of this in the near--
well, I'll be showing
a demo of this
later on in the session.
So very exciting announcement.
I think it has tremendous
benefit for mobile web
developers.
MIHAI IONESCU: Absolutely.
I'm looking forward
to the demo.
What else?
Oh, an announcement about
your questions on
the forums and Google+.
We're getting a lot of those.
And we want to consolidate
them in just one place.
And the best place to do that,
we think it's Stack Overflow.
We've already been consolidating
a lot of Stack
Overflow questions from
other Google APIs.
So look for an announcement
early next week.
We're moving all our questions
to Stack Overflow.
And the tag, of course,
will be Google Wallet.
So we'll announce it
on the forums and
on the Google+ page.
PENG YING: Yep.
So shall we talk about
the benefits?
There's a few benefits--
MIHAI IONESCU: Of course.
PENG YING: --of using
Stack Overflow.
So one of the ones that I've
seen, well, one of the ones
that we've noticed is that
when you're using Google
Groups, which is our typical
one-to-many forum support
platform, is that when you have
a question about, let's
say, Google Wallet for digital
goods or checkout or something
else, these groups are kind of
isolated communities where the
topics are all solely focused
on this one topic.
And within Stack Overflow,
instead of that, it's a huge
community where these questions
are tagged with the
topics that they're on.
So what this enables us to do
is instead of having these
small, segregated groups, you
have one huge community with
everybody answering, everybody
interacting.
So we hope that by switching
over to Stack Overflow, we
provide both a better
experience, and we help build
out the community for Google
commerce-related products.
MIHAI IONESCU: Definitely
much easier to search.
And right now, there's
also some
cross-pollination among APIs.
Developers use different APIs.
Stack Overflow is a much
better place to find
information about all available
Wallet APIs.
Good.
What else?
What else is new for
the next few weeks?
We have some new conferences
that we're going to present
Wallet and talk about
Wallet APIs at.
A very exciting one--
Google for Entrepreneurs
in Kansas City.
So if you're from the Midwest
area, make sure you make time
to attend that.
It's on November 13 at the
Kauffman Conference Center in
Kansas City.
Cool.
So let's do the demo.
PENG YING: All right.
Let's do the demo.
If you could--
let's take a look
at my laptop.
And then so right now, this
is the Five Guys.
We announced Five Guys, one of
our premier launch partners.
And the idea is that
normally I would--
so think of this as the
Five Guys mobile site.
And then what we're going to be
doing here is just taking a
look at how the flow is
different between using Google
Wallet for digital goods and how
it can simplify the flow.
So let's say I want to order
lunch, and there's a
Five Guys around me.
This is the one in San Diego,
which has Google Wallet for
online commerce enabled.
So I just want to
get a burger--
regular hamburger, delicious,
delicious hamburgers, all the
Way, of course.
MIHAI IONESCU: All the way?
PENG YING: All the way.
And then here you can
see it, the Buy with
Google Wallet button.
So if I want to continue
my typical
checkout, I would do that.
And then I would have to either
login or create an
account or checkout as guest.
And then I'd have to enter in
some additional information
such as credit card
names, info.
MIHAI IONESCU: So how
much data is that?
PENG YING: It's a few
extra fields.
But in this case, so if I'm
using an Android device, I'm
already typically logged
in, which is
something I can leverage.
And in this case, I'm also
logged into their browser, so
it knows who I am.
I can simply click Buy
with Google Wallets.
I can enable this transaction.
And then Use the Same Shipping
Address, Use Google Wallet.
So this is pre-authorizing Five
Guys to have access to my
Wallet credentials.
So next time, you'll see
how the flow changes.
I'll do this twice.
I'm going to continue here.
And then boom.
So it has all my payment
credentials and payment
information and contact
information.
Now, if I place this order,
I'll actually get a
cheeseburger in San Diego.
And I'm in Mountain View, so
unfortunately, I'm won't
complete this one.
But we can go over to--
we made a sample as
well, so we go to
wallet.java.appspot.com.
Actually, let's go to
our documentation.
Because the sample is also
iFramed in our documentation.
So go to developers.googl
e.com/wallet-online.
And so this is our sample and
our documentation as well.
And I just want to walk
you through it.
So if I wanted to buy a camera
on our sample, I would add it
to the cart.
And then here, I could either
buy with Google Wallet or
Continue Checkout.
The button changed a little bit,
which is why the spacing
is a little bit off.
But that one's going to be fixed
in the very near future.
So I'm already pre-authorized
on this site.
So instead of confirming my
selections about my method of
payment, about my shipping
address, I can simply click
Buy with Google Wallet.
And it automatically passes the
information over to the merchant.
And in this case, it's Sandbox,
fake information, so
no real-world transaction's
going to be processed.
I can place this order,
and I'm done.
It might take a second,
a quick second.
And there you go.
I have my receipt.
I have purchased my good.
I didn't have to add any of
my billing or shipping
information in my mobile
device, which is
super painful at times.
And I can continue on with
my rest of the day.
Let's say if I wanted to buy
another item, or in this case,
maybe I want to upgrade
my camera, I can go
through the same flow.
And because I'm pre-authorized
now, what you can also do is
tie the Continue Checkout
button with the
Google Wallet call.
And so Continue Checkout can
also request credentials from
Google Wallet.
Think of it as a OAuth2-style
payment credential access, so
something that could be
potentially super powerful.
I can continue through it.
And I'm done.
And because what's happening
here is that Google Wallet is
passing over a one-time cards to
the merchant, merchants and
developers don't really have
to change their existing
payment rails.
So it's super, super simplistic
integration.
And we can walk through-- well,
I don't think we need to
walk through it today.
But you can take a look at the
documentation yourself.
It's under Tutorial.
Right now, sign up,
unfortunately, is closed.
We're only working with
the partners.
But if you are interested in
becoming one of our upcoming
or future partners, then you
can sign up through--
there's a link on
the FAQ page.
It's right at the bottom.
So contact us.
And then we are always looking
to add additional partners.
Cool.
So if you want to find out
more, visit this site,
developers.googl
e.com/wallet-online.
Play with the APIs or play
with the sample.
Take a look at the APIs.
And then if you're really
interested, express your
interest by contacting us.
MIHAI IONESCU: What other
merchants do we have that
there are live with this
API right now?
PENG YING: So we have
1-800-Flowers is
live with this API.
And I forget the last one.
MIHAI IONESCU: Rockport.
PENG YING: Is it Rockport?
MIHAI IONESCU: Rockport, yeah.
PENG YING: OK, so Rockport is
also live with this API.
And we hope we get a
few, or many more.
MIHAI IONESCU: If you want to
buy flowers or shoes or--
PENG YING: Yeah.
Flowers, shoes, or
cheeseburgers.
MIHAI IONESCU: We've covered
the entire spectrum.
But flowers would
be really nice.
And you want to buy
them on the spot.
And you have only your
mobile device.
PENG YING: Exactly.
MIHAI IONESCU: You don't need
to insert all the address
information, all the
card information.
Just one click--
PENG YING: And you're done.
MIHAI IONESCU: --your loved
one gets the flowers.
PENG YING: I can see this
being really useful,
especially for mobile
ordering.
I can see instead of going to
whatever fast food place where
we're getting lunch and then
waiting in line and then
placing your order and waiting
for it to be cooked, that
people can just go on their
phone and place their order
ahead of time and then
go and pick it up.
I think that's something that's
a huge time saver.
There's also a lot of other
potentials in this.
I think mobile commerce
is one field
that's definitely growing.
So with that, there's a lot of
opportunity here, like maybe
hotels or something.
MIHAI IONESCU: More
time to eat, and
more time to buy stuff.
PENG YING: Like hotels and
travel will probably be
another big area.
MIHAI IONESCU: It's making
lives easier and
commerce more efficient.
Thanks, Peng, for the demo.
We hope you liked it.
And make sure you go check
out the demo line or the
documentation.
And if you're interested in
trying it in the Sandbox and
learning more about the API, use
the merchant sign-up form.
And we'll get in contact
with you.
Great.
So next, let's look
at some questions.
We've got quite a few questions
submitted in the
forums and in the Moderator.
Charles started the first one.
So it's a subscription
API-related question, that's
subscription for digital
goods API.
And the question is, "Can I
create a subscription with no
expiration date?"
So that is a very
good question.
And currently, the API requires
you to specify the
number of times the subscription
payment recurs.
So you cannot create an
open-ended subscription with
no expiration date.
But it is indeed a very
valid case and
something that makes sense.
So we are working to add that
additional functionality.
And we hope to have it soon.
So thank you for the question.
And it's something that's
in the works.
You want to take the next one?
PENG YING: Sure.
So "When will the Save-to-Wallet
Offers API be
generally available to online
merchants?" We get questions
about when things are going to
be released all the time, and
when will they be available to
merchants, or when are we
going to do this.
Unfortunately, we can never
comment on any of that.
I wish we could.
But in this case, all I
can say is soon, in
the upcoming future.
MIHAI IONESCU: We do have some
documentation, though, if
people want to learn
more about it.
PENG YING: We do.
I think--
I forget.
I haven't taken a look
at the API myself.
So I don't know too much about
how available it is, either.
But there is documentation
available.
MIHAI IONESCU: I'll
take the next one.
Along the same lines, "Any word
on support for Sprint
Galaxy Note 2?" So I think
we support all
Galaxy devices on Sprint.
Sprint is one of our partners
for Google Wallet.
And I would be surprised if
Galaxy Node doesn't work.
I may be wrong.
But to make sure you have a
device that works, there is a
list of available devices.
And it should be listed there.
And the list is in
the Help Session.
So if you go to
wallet.google.com, and at the
bottom of the page you click on
Help, you will see the Help
Center, and then there's a
link to eligible devices.
And most if not all of Sprint
devices are listed there.
So you can check that.
Next one.
PENG YING: I guess this
one's for me.
"T-Mobile--
what are the chances of an
agreement coming through or at
least support for the Galaxy S3
for Google Wallet?" Again,
we're working with all
of the carriers.
And I can't say any more
details, but we're working
with the powers that be.
MIHAI IONESCU: So Galaxy
now works on MetroPCS.
We just announced availability
on MetroPCS.
And T-Mobile is buying
MetroPCS.
So you never know.
PENG YING: I heard MetroPCS
is growing a lot.
They've had huge subscriber
growth.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right,
I'll take the next one.
The question is, "When will
support for international
buyers be added to the Google
Wallet for online commerce
API?" So we just talked about
it, the Google Wallet for
online commerce.
We saw demo that Peng did.
And right now, it's released
to a limited number of
participating partners that we
just launched with yesterday.
It's not even fully available
in the United States.
Things will slowly
be released.
If you are a United States
merchant, you can
apply to test it.
We just showed you the sign-up
link in the FAQ section.
And then we hope to have more
merchants available soon, also
internationally.
PENG YING: Yep.
That'll be very awesome.
We want to expand as quickly
as possible.
MIHAI IONESCU: It is a
really useful API.
And we've seen a lot of interest
from merchants.
And we love international
merchants.
Next one?
PENG YING: Next one's for me.
"Will there be any APIs exposed
for adding loyalty
cards?" Again, I wish I could
comment on things.
I mean, I can't speculate on
when things are going to be
launched or if they're going
to be launched, even.
So I guess it's going to
be a waiting game.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, which one
is going to be released first?
PENG YING: If it's launched,
then it's launched.
And then you'll know.
MIHAI IONESCU: I'll
take the next one,
which is somehow related.
There is one merchant who
says, "We are running a
universal loyalty platform
using NFC tags.
If I want users to be able to
adopt into the Google Wallet
ecosystem, what is the tag
specification to be used?" So
if I understand the question
correctly, it is about
NFC-enabled loyalty cards.
For example, at the grocery
store, instead of swiping the
card, you just tap the card.
And that'll be your
loyalty card.
If you have multiple cards like
that, definitely it makes
sense to add all of them
into the phone.
And don't go--
when you switch retailers--
PENG YING: --NFC to NFC.
MIHAI IONESCU: And then you
just tap the phone, and
automatically it
will just work.
So instead of carrying
a lot of cards, you
just carry the phone.
So as we talked in the past,
this would fit perfectly
within the Wallet ecosystem.
Right now, as we said earlier,
we don't have an API.
But, yeah, it's something
that is definitely worth
considering.
PENG YING: Yeah, they could
even-- so like, we do some
stuff in the background, too.
So it doesn't have to
be NFC-enabled.
It could be maybe
a back-end API.
When the transaction gets to
Google, then we can do
something with the transaction
information as well.
MIHAI IONESCU: So an API for
the merchant, we enable the
loyalty card directly
on the phone.
That would be something great.
Let's see.
I guess that's it
for questions.
Anything else we want
to announce?
So we can recap.
So we had major release
this week.
PENG YING: Google Wallet for
online commerce, now available
for consumers.
Soon for developers and
merchants like yourselves.
MIHAI IONESCU: And then next
week, look for an announcement
for Stack Overflow.
We're moving all our questions,
all our support to
Stack Overflow across
all Wallet APIs.
And if you're in the Midwest
area, Kansas City, there is a
Google for Entrepreneurs
Conference at the Kauffman
Center, November 13.
If you have time, it's going
to be really cool.
Make sure to attend
and sign up.
PENG YING: Awesome.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
Well, thank you.
PENG YING: Short and
sweet this week.
Next week we have a great show
for you-- or not next week.
In two weeks, we have another
great session for you.
We'll be bringing on a partner
to showcase how they've
implemented Google Wallet
for digital goods.
MIHAI IONESCU: Monetization.
PENG YING: Yeah, monetization.
MIHAI IONESCU: It's
making money.
PENG YING: It's going
to be fun.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
Thanks, everyone.
And see you in two weeks.
PENG YING: See you.
MIHAI IONESCU: Bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]